[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In this
video, we're going
to discuss committed use
discounts and sustained use
discounts.
We'll provide a
brief explanation
of what they are,
how to use them,
and how to track them
in your billing account.
Let's get started.
First up, committed
use discounts or CUDs
provide discounted prices
for certain cloud services
in exchange for committing to
a consistent amount of usage
for a one or three-year period.
There are two types of CUDs--
spend-based and resource-based.
Spend-based CUDs provide
a discount in exchange
for your commitment to spend
a minimum amount for a service
each month.
They are purchased and measured
in terms of dollars per hour.
A limited number of services
support spend-based commitments
such as Cloud SQL.
As you can see in this
example Cloud SQL CUD,
the commitment amount is defined
based on the on-demand price.
You then agree to pay a
monthly discounted fee
for the commitment for
the duration of the term.
For some services,
like Cloud SQL,
the CUD is purchased
for a specific region
and is applied towards
all service usage
within that region.
Other Cloud Services
apply spend-based CUDs
towards all usage
across all regions.
Resource-based CUDs,
on the other hand,
provide a discount in
exchange for your commitment
to run a certain amount
of resources continuously
each month.
For example, Compute
Engine CUDs are
measured in terms of the amount
of resources such as vCPUs
and memory and work on most
Compute Engine machine types,
including predefined and
custom machine types.
You can make
separate commitments
for GPUs and local SSD as well.
Discounts apply to the aggregate
number of vCPUs, memory, GPUs,
and local SSDs within a region.
So they are not affected by
changes to your instances
machine setup.
Like some spend-based
CUDs, resource-based CUDs
are purchased on a
per region basis.
Let's head into the console
and see how to view, purchase,
and track usage for your CUDs.
First up, spending-based CUDs.
We'll start with a
viewing your CUDs.
For this task, you must be a
billing account administrator
or billing account viewer on
the Cloud Billing account.
From the navigation
menu, select Billing.
If you have more than
one Cloud Billing
account, choose the billing
account for which you'd
like to view associated CUDs.
Then in the left-hand navigation
menu, select Commitments.
On the Commitments
Landing page, you'll
see a summary of your
committed use discounts
by commitment type.
To view a detailed analysis
of a specific spend-based
commitment, you can
select it from the list.
Next up, to purchase
spend-based CUDs,
you must be a billing account
administrator for the account.
At the top of the
screen, click Purchase.
This will bring up a dialog box.
Choose the product
in the dropdown
and then complete the details.
Review the commitment
summary and terms
and then click Purchase.
Finally, to analyze
spend-based CUDs,
you must be a billing
account administrator
or a billing account viewer
on the Cloud Billing account.
In the left-hand
navigation menu,
select Commitment Analysis.
This page shows the details
of the selected commitment
for the period
specified in the filter,
including summary
cards, a stacked bar
chart, and a summary table
of the commitment's totals.
More details on reading
the Analysis page
can be found in the
documentation linked below.
Next up, viewing,
purchasing, and analyzing
resource-based commitments
for Compute Engine.
To view commitments
for Compute Engine,
you must be a compute
admin or compute viewer
on the project in which you
purchase the commitments.
Make sure you have selected
the correct project, then
head to the left-hand
navigation menu
and choose Compute Engine,
then Committed Use Discounts.
This will bring you to a list of
your commitments, their status,
and additional details.
To purchase commitments
for Compute Engine,
you must be a compute admin on
the project or a project owner.
To purchase a
machine-type commitment,
click the Purchase Commitment
button at the top of the page,
name your commitment,
and complete the details,
then click Purchase.
To analyze your Compute
Engine commitments,
you can use the same process
as spend-based commitments.
This means you must be a
billing account administrator
or billing account viewer
on the Cloud Billing
account associated with
the project containing
the commitments.
From the navigation
menu, select Billing.
Choose the billing account
associated with the project.
In the left-hand navigation
menu, select Commitments,
then click on Compute
Engine Commitment Analysis.
This page shows the details
of the selected commitment
for the period
specified in the filter,
including summary
cards, a stacked bar
chart, and a summary table
of the commitment's totals.
This is also where
you can change
the scope of your
Compute Engine CUDs
from project level,
which is default,
to billing account level.
With discount sharing
enabled, the CUDs
apply across all eligible usage
and all projects associated
with this billing account.
Any Compute Engine
resources that
do not qualify for
committed use discounts
automatically qualify for
sustained use discounts.
Sustained use discounts
are automatic discounts
for running specific
Compute Engine
resources a significant
portion of the billing month.
Sustained use discounts
give you up to 30%
off, whereas committed
use discounts give you
up to 57% to 70% off.
SUDs require no commitment
and are applied automatically
when you meet the requirements
through your resource usage
without any action on your part.
SUDs will automatically
appear on your bill
at the end of the billing cycle.
You can view your
sustained use discounts
on the cost breakdown page
located in the left-hand nav.
Head over to the documentation
to check out more details.
[MUSIC PLAYING]